[Musique]
avec ce passeport votre information est
le gagnant du concours lune de miel 1
une semaine
all inclusive pour de petites annonces
quelqu'un que je détestais ça sur ses
bons jours à l'hommage
si je peux aider notre la gourmette
santa claus comme le pape commençait
jean-paul plus loin si ce monsieur
saucisses n'a pas de chance alors on a
pensé que vous pourriez parle pas de la
vôtre ouais c'est encore moi je voulais
juste te dire que je pense à toi là tu
veut la récupérer ya pas 36 méthodes à
la cub merci pour la chemise pour le
slip j'en prendrai qu'un jour avec au
verso
pour les boissons on mélange mais moi
deux envie qu'on trouve au brun attire
alcool deux tiers de hockey 4 barbra all
inclusive
on a vu
c'est jean-paul m'est arrivé j'ai rien
contre mais tu m'as péter dessus non non
non je suis papeete c'est une bulle de
maillots je vois souvent une femme d'un
certain âge c'est à dire je vois le
train pur murs très très très dur
je suis surtout en temps de regarder
mais ça a alors lu on drague épisode
comme ça j'ai réglé une fois pour tout
est légal téléphonie allemand d'avion
paloise pas tout à rester jean paul
c'est pas des vacances pour moi mettez
jamais de bonne humeur willow merde ta
gueule qu'est ce qu'elle a ma gueule
arrête de faire le jeune tout le monde
ici appelle la gueule t'as pas compris
ça
je suis rien moi c'est ça c'est rien
oh
[Musique]